Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. Without a merry entrance Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
Thank you for listening. I know from speaking with many of you that it can feel incredibly disheartening when we are coming up in the field of psychology and perhaps people are having multiple application cycles to becoming a clinical psychologist or maybe even other types of psychologists too. And you feel like you're getting interviews but not getting the result, not getting the job that you desire. And sometimes
the feedback can be varied. It can be about performance in interview. It can be about, you know, academic skills and resources needing strengthening. And sometimes people just feel that they're not even getting shortlisted for interview. And it can be really disheartening. It can make people feel, maybe this isn't for me. Maybe I should give up. Maybe I should do something different. And I guess when I was an assistant psychologist, it could feel like I was a little bit piecemeal, really,
trying to piece things together and convince people that I was going to be a great trainee clinical psychologist. And certainly I was one. You know, I did reasonably at that. And I loved my assistant roles. But you might have heard there's a new kid on the block, the CAP, the Clinical Associate in Psychology. And you might be like, I don't really know what that is. I don't know how that would work. I've kind of heard it, but I never quite remember what the initials are. Cap. So just imagine it's a cap you're wearing. And so I thought it'd be really lovely to get someone along to talk to us who is themselves a CAP but also works at university helping to
train future CAPs too. I have invited Elise along who is herself a qualified CAP but also works in academia helping to train future CAPs at Plymouth University. So with no further ado, let's get on, let's meet Elise and see what she and I have got to say. And I will look forward to catching you on the other side. Welcome along to our guest today, Elise Dyer, who is a clinical tutor and a lecturer on the MSc CAP programme at Plymouth Uni. Hi Elise, welcome along. Hi, hi, lovely to be here and lovely to meet you. You too, thank you so much for joining us. So for those who don't know what the CAP initials are, could you tell us a little bit about that please? Yeah of course it's a new program it's Clinical Associate Psychologist MSc program most universities in the UK now offering this program it's a collaborative MSc apprenticeship program
NHS funds this program so NHS services work with universities their local universities to provide this um apprenticeship program it's 18 months and apprentices apprentice caps train with us um plymouth university and they spend two three days in their workplace learning on the job if you like so they get a chance to practice what they learn in their lectures. That sounds brilliant it's really great to know that such a program exists that you can be funded to do an MSc and also learn really valuable skills and get that clinical experience at the same time? Absolutely, absolutely.
I think it's a brilliant opportunity really for people, psychological graduates. So only psychological graduates, I'm afraid, can apply to these programmes because you are trained in clinical skills and psychology degree is viewed as a foundation to build on those skills. And ideally, apprentices should have a couple of years of experience in the field as well. It doesn't have to be paid experience but it's ideal for them to have some clinical experience as well. The program was developed to offer opportunity to especially people who cannot get on the clinical psychology program doctorate because as you know it's incredibly competitive and there are a lot of psychology
graduates and experienced clinicians and working in ap posts or other posts trying years and years and years to get onto the doctorate. But unfortunately, it's not happening. So we get those people applying to clinical associate psychology programs to become a CAP. Because CAP skills, essential skills, are quite in line with clinical psychologists skills as in the core competencies are providing assessment formulation intervention and consultation so competencies skills to be able to work with people indirectly providing indirect clinical skills, if you like. So in that sense, it's quite similar to clinical psychologist competencies.
But the main difference is CAPS are semi-autonomous practitioners. So CAPS must be supervised by a qualified clinical psychologist or a psychologist applied psychologist that had changed recently it initially it was a clinical psychologist but it has changed now it's an applied psychologist so it could be counselling psychologist or any other applied psychologist in the service can supervise the CAP. So semi-autonomous practitioners. So that's the main difference. Thank you. So it's like it sounds like it's kind of assistant work, but with much more structure and, you know, more, I don't know, more, it's more applied. It's more of an applied profession. Absolutely. More applied, more hands-on, and a bit more autonomy
compared to assistant psychologists, I suppose, because CAPS, again, under clinical supervision, can provide a variety of tasks in a service, assessment formulation intervention running group groups um yeah you know doing um integrative therapies because they are trained in variety of therapeutic models um so they could really provide those interventions to their clients in their specific services um so and because they are trained in a specific service there is depth of knowledge there um i guess compared to assistant psychologists because assistant psychologists are usually just psychology graduates whereas caps
as well as doing psychology undergrad degree they they train in this specific program, 18 months of program. And they go through a quite robust learning process, really. They have, for instance, they have 119 knowledge, skill, behaviors. They train in, they learn and they demonstrate in order to graduate as a CAP. So by the time they complete the programme, they have various skills and competencies that I guess takes them a step ahead, if you like, compared to other professions at AP level. It sounds it sounds brilliant and actually it sounds like something i would have really really liked um when i was an aspiring clinical psychologist myself
because i did feel a little bit de-skilled you know i felt like i didn't really have a thing you know you know and it is hard to get therapy experience when working as an assistant. I found certainly at the time, I think things have changed a great deal since I, since I was coming up in the field of psychology. But I really like the sound of this program and how it trains people and it gives people experience of what it will be like ultimately, if they do go on to do doctorate but of course you might choose not to you might choose to stay as a cat because you really enjoy that absolutely absolutely again some people like you say um they come onto the program with a kind of long-term goal of okay i'll complete this program and i'll work in the field for a couple of years and i'll
still go and apply to doctorate which is fine it's it's a choice but some people do change their mind and stay working as a cap a cap program also another difference compared to other kind of foundational level professions if you like. CAPs are trained as band five clinicians and upon qualification they work as a band six clinician in services. However, things are changing and expanding, roles are expanding in services and there are opportunities for career development and applying to band seven roles as well for instance in cornwall we have a colleague who after cap qualification secured a band seven position within the nhs and now they're performing that role um so there is that option and opportunity
um as well that's really interesting and really good to know and it really does help people to make you know and earn a livable wage whilst they're training as well so you'd get when you're training you get the band five but you also get your tuition fees paid as well is that right elise absolutely absolutely yes it's it's all paid yes amazing that sounds incredible um how did it come about as a as a thing as a program do you know much about the history of it uh yes uh basically uh can laid law from exeter university and he used to be a clinical psychologist lead. But if I remember right, he might be retired now or just about to. So he was receiving feedback and he was observing that a lot of aspiring clinical psychologists are suffering, if you like, not being able to get on to the program,
feeling really frustrated, feeling really disappointed. And we're losing. And he was thinking, well, we're losing these psychology graduates and really potentially good clinicians. So he and Mike Hutchinson from Exeter University, again, I think they started talking about how about looking into this training program where we train people to work as an associate psychologist and train them within a shorter program instead of three years doctorate program, but still give them depth of knowledge to work as a good clinician in the field. So that's how the programme started developing, really, people noticing, people in the field, clinical psychologists, because both are clinical psychologists, noticing there's a gap in psychology fields. So we could really create clinicians who can work,
who we can place them between assistant psychologists and clinical psychologists, because before CAPS, there was nothing in between, if you like. So that's how it was created, really, noticing that gap and witnessing psychological graduates not getting onto the programme and feeling utterly disappointed. So that's how it came about. This sounds incredible. They did a really good job there, I think.
I know last year it came as a bit of a shock in September, on the 1st of September, in fact, when the Clearinghouse announced that there would be HEE limits for funding. Is this programme part of that as well, the Higher Education England funding rule? At the moment, it is, yes. So, yeah, if people are training as a cap um yes so they need to after qualification they need to be staying and working um is it two years or three years i think it's two so initially on the first of september they said it was like a blanket from then didn't they but there'd been a lot of lobbying um and yeah it's been i think it's been overruled and
delayed um until next september to allow people a chance to um adjust you know was that as much as a surprise to the universities as it was to us in the field as well you know when they just announced that blanket ban yes although it was a surprise, a bit of a shock, but I personally think it's a good thing. I'm not going to deny. I think I agree with the idea because when you go on to a program and when you train, you really need that consolidation time to be able to really apply your skills and learning and to feel really comfortable and confident in what you learned and how you do that. And also, I must admit, the program, it's a brilliant program, but it's an intense program. It's not a breeze at all. And, you know, there's a lot of assignments to get through and a lot of skills to learn and to apply in your service so it takes its toll if you like and i think jumping from one program tiring hard work to another three years of another intense program although i haven't done clinical psychology
doctorate i have friends who have done and who tell me similarly it's hard work it's it's you know it's not a walking in the path. So jumping from CAP course to doctorate would have been really hard. So I think it's a good thing that people will be forced, if you like, to take that two years breathing space and just work. Forget about training for a while and just apply what you learned. Consolidate that learning and, yeah yeah perform as a clinician if you like yeah i don't disagree that it's not a good idea um and it certainly will make people less impulsive you know thinking about actually whether this is going to be right for them and
whether that is something that they want to commit for but i think the issue was it took away people's informed choice didn't it initially when they said i can't do it for two years and it's like well that's not fair you know yeah you're right and it and it wasn't sort of it was just like a last minute thing it just came about but luckily they pulled back and they allowed people to apply and get onto the courses and now hopefully people have enough knowledge and they can make informed decisions from now on. Yeah and it's actually an aspiring psychologist himself who really spearheaded that campaign to get that overturned Erkan he did such an amazing job he's now secured a place on training this year as well which is incredible but it's helped so many people you know had that not happened it's unlikely they
would have changed their their decision at that stage so you know there's a little message there that if we don't agree with things we can raise our heads and raise our hands and you know fight for fight for what we believe in but um it's interesting to know there's assignments in there as well are there exams too Elise? Yeah no exams uh but we have um we have variety of um assessments and um essays case reports. They also have, as I said, 119 knowledge, skill, behaviours that they have to demonstrate to their clinical supervisor in order to be signed off. And at the end of the programme, we have end point assessment. So what happens is throughout a year they learn all these skills knowledge behaviors an end point assessment is set as a day or in two
days they demonstrate their skills and competencies that gain they gained from the program and in role plays so we have four stations assessment station and governance risk station formulation station intervention station so they go through those stations and they demonstrate role play with an actor and they demonstrate those clinical skills live and they are assessed by an independent assessor and they get their marks as a pass or fail so I guess the difference of CAP apprenticeship program is not only they write the same assignments and case reports but at the end they have that end point assessment process it's it's i mean it can be seen as a uh showcase you're actually celebrating what you're what you gained and you're showing off your skills if you like but needless to say it does create some anxiety in apprentices as well, because it's live and you're role playing and no one likes role plays.
I actually quite like a role play. I was an anomaly in my cohort for enjoying that. But, yeah, I can imagine that when it comes to, you know, to that the four station day um the anxieties are certainly running high but it sounds incredible and um you know doing it with actors as well i know some clinical um doctorate courses employ actors to come in and do things um on selection days and one time they got told to pair it back because they were like really wild and too like almost like traumatizing for people so they got told maybe next time don't be so we're not trying to scare our applicants um so the 18 is it an 18 month placement that runs for the duration of the course yes yeah
18 months yeah so ideally you know maternity leave aside for supervisors it would be um you'd get the same supervisor running from start to finish is that ideal is that the gold standard it's absolutely ideal and gold standard but as you know in services unfortunately that doesn't always happen and sometimes it's unlucky a clinical supervisor may decide to stop working or get another job. And it does happen occasionally. It's not, you know, it's not too often, but occasionally it does happen that you can get a new clinical supervisor during your 18 months program. But ideally, of course, they would have one supervisor taking them 18 months program but ideally of course they would have one supervisor taking them through the program that would be ideal but i do know how how busy lives um and
conflicting demands work as well is there like a kind of mid-placement visit or the multiple mid-placement visits uh we we don't have visits from university as such. I think that's the difference between clinical psychology, doctorate program and CAP program. So as clinical tutors, we don't visit our tutees at all, but their clinical supervisor work with them closely. And of course, they're embedded in their service. their their manager their colleagues their MDT is you know keeping a close eye on on apprentices and work with them in order to help them and support them to gain those skills. Great and are there teaching blocks with at uni or is it done kind of just the days of the week oh it there is definitely
teaching blocks when they start they have a teaching block with university and then they go to their placement and when they start their placement there is one or two days of uni days but yeah it's mainly done in teaching blocks and then service great um i feel like i'm firing loads of questions at you but i find this so interesting and i know our audience will as well are all of the placements in adult mental health services or are they across the lifespan could you tell us a bit about the nature of the placement basis please yeah sure it's all depends on which services need caps and what service and which service come to us to university saying can you please train our um some people for us some caps for us but it's across the lifespan it could be so for instance currently we are training adult mental health services.
People, CAPS will work in adult services, but we also train CAMHS clinicians. So I was trained within CAMHS as a CAMHS CAP. So we now train CAMHS CAPS as well. But we also have plans for training CAP caps in learning difficulties, you know, any other any other secondary mental health. So it could be across the lifespan, elderly, working with, you know, elderly, older adults. Brilliant. So you'd know at the point that you were replying to the university, what the programme was, and so which area you might end up working in absolutely absolutely in that sense again it's different from clinical psychology program you apply to
nhs service so best place to keep an eye on is um nhs jobs because these jobs are advertised by the services. So when you look at a job, you will see which service, where is that service and what they offer, basically. So you could be looking at, okay, well, CAMHS in Cornwall is recruiting CAPs, you know, apprentice CAPs to work within CAMHS as CAMHS clinicians, CAMHS caps basically or you could be looking into an advert to work in adult services or learning difficulty services so if you like the sound of working and training in that particular service and area, then please do apply.
But if you feel like, I'm not sure, maybe I wanna work in CAMHS services, not learning difficulties, then you've gotta wait until CAMHS CAHPS opportunity becomes available. Again, that's the difference between clinical psychology doctorate and CAPS. Clinical psychology has breadth of knowledge. You have different services you're placed for about four
to six months moving from one service to another. And it could be children's services, learning difficulties, adults, et cetera. Whereas CAPS train in one particular service, so depth of knowledge. If you're going into learning difficulties service, you'll train in that for 18 months and you'll, upon qualification, you'll work in that particular area if you like. So you have a depth of knowledge, not breadth. OK, so you wouldn't necessarily be able to apply for a qualified CAP role in a child service if, for example, you're training out older adults because it's not necessarily transferable. Not necessarily. But again, there are talks about how the core skills and competencies are transferable those you know assessment formulation um especially assessment formulation um skills and to a certain extent intervention skills so if it depends on service really there's no one would stop you from applying to a different service, even though, say, you're qualified as a CAP within CAMHS.
But you could go and apply to any other service saying, well, I've got the foundation skills. I've got those transferable skills and I'm happy to receive top up training from you. And maybe there could be an in-house training to add those extra specific skills to be able to work in that service so it could happen so there's no hard rules about you're qualified in this you can't apply to any other service okay that's really good to know and when people are looking on nhs jobs what terms should be these should they be searching for if they're looking for these training roles? They could use search terms apprenticeship, clinical associate psychology, CAP. So I think those should bring up those roles.
Great. Thank you. And I guess, well, whilst people are trying to learn a bit more about it, they could look at doing a national search, couldn't they? So that they're looking at who's recruiting, what they're saying, what the person spec and the job description is, if they do want to have an overview of what's around at the moment. Absolutely. Absolutely. And also, I think this is an important thing as well for people. Our program is entirely remote, remote teaching, online teaching. And I believe most universities provide CAP program as a remote teaching. their NHS placement service so they've got to live nearby their service but they don't have to live near university so we have we are in Plymouth university is in Plymouth but we have Southern
Health from Southampton area or we have Oxford CAMHS training with us we have Cornwall CAMHS training with us so I think online remote teaching is really effective and helping people greatly really I think this is one of Covid's silver linings isn't it that universities now can provide those online fully online programs. Absolutely and it's all about improving accessibility for people and being able to fit it around their lives you know I'm a I'm a mother myself and I know you are too and it just helps you to be a bit more flexible absolutely absolutely yes I understand you were part of the second cohort um where you trained could you tell us a little bit about whether you enjoyed training how you found it and all of that absolutely absolutely yeah I I was the second cohort in Cornwall and in fact I was
working as a primary mental health worker within CAMHS part-time and when this opportunity became available I was I was highly interested and I applied and I I secured the position and I thoroughly enjoyed um training um it wasn't an apprenticeship when I did it it was just an MSc uh degree um so I trained within CAMHS with and I knew service. I knew the people I worked with. So I was already embedded in the team, which was quite helpful, actually. And the training was really good. Lecturers came from Exeter University. It was Exeter University to Cornwall to train us.
It was back then. It was face to face. And, yeah, in my cohort, there were 26 of us and we were all highly motivated, bonded well. It was really good experience, really hard work. As I said earlier, it wasn't a breeze. So, you know, you it's it's you've got to be well organized and highly motivated and uh you've got to be on top of it i guess to be able to keep up with it um but but all good experience you know i i would i would do it again and again so it's it's lovely experience i'm quite tempted actually elise i won't lie up in I've been qualified as a psychologist since 2011. Do you get much of a chance to do cohort bonding these days when it is online only?
Because you might be the only associate training cap in your service. Are you getting much time to do any cohort bonding? Yeah, good question. We have hybrid days. Basically, we ask our apprentices to go into their service from their locality in fives or six. So they have hybrid learning days where they learn together and we provide them tasks on those days where they actually do it together so then there's a bit of bonding as well and most of our cohorts what they do they all create their own cohort whatsapp and then they always text each other and you know talk and liaise and help each
other support each other so there is is, although, you know, in theory, it may sound like, oh, it's all remote, they may not bond, but they actually find ways to bond. Good. I'm so pleased to hear it because actually, when I was training as a clinical psychologist, and even when I was an assistant psychologist, my favourite bits of those roles was the relationships I made with people doing the same thing at the same time. So it's really important when we are trying to avoid burnout on the way up. It's really important to have peer support and to be a fly on the wall in those WhatsApp groups. Hey, Liz.
Same here. same here um could you give us some of your top tips for avoiding burnout on the way and on the way up and through psychology careers if that's okay absolutely i i guess we've got to practice what we preach as psychologists really having a good work-life balance and making sure your boundaries i I love this word boundaries. So, you know, if your working hours are nine to five, please do stop at five, turn off your work laptop, do not check your work emails and really look after yourself. Have a bit of me time at weekends,
spend quality time with your family, friends. Go and do your hobbies. It could be as simple as just go for a walk and have fresh air or go and have, I don't know, coffee and cake. Just have those little treats, simple pleasures in life to keep you going, if you like. I'm lucky I live in cornwall so i swim regularly especially these days it's just god sent really after work i just go and jump in the sea um so really claiming those times back like me times and making sure that you look after yourself and and yeah being organized does help with that kind of keeping a notebook if you like
giving yourself say for instance i can okay i can do a bit of reading between this time and that time but then from 7 p.m till 8 p.m for instance i have my i don't know dinner with my partner or after that i'm watching a bit of netflix um you know i'm i don't know i dinner with my partner or after that, I'm watching a bit of Netflix. You know, I'm I don't know, I'm going to bed at such time and definitely not thinking about work or anything. Really being strict in a way that you switch off at weekends and be on working hours. I think it's hugely important. Really, really important. Yeah, compartmentalising it.
And whoever we think we're serving when we're working longer hours, we're often not, you know. Boundaries are really, really important. I love the sound of you being able to dive into the sea. I live in the middle of England and I'm so jealous of that. That sounds incredible. No, really good. I'm lucky.
We're lucky in Cornwall it's lovely all moved down I might do I might do I might look into it it's been such a pleasure talking to you and learning more about this incredible training scheme thank you so much for your time I know people will be super super interested to learn more about it because it feels like this sort of mysterious newcomer yes yes yeah no it's been lovely talking to you too and i hope it does help some people to make decisions and choices and i highly recommend psychology graduates or people who need an alternative career to clinical psychology if you like um so yeah and do contact me if you have any any further questions or if anyone wants to know
anything further i'm happy to respond and reply as much as possible brilliant i'll make sure i pop your details in the show notes. Do you want people to start following Plymouth University on socials? Is that a good thing to do? Oh it's it's an excellent thing to do it's one of the best universities and I'm not saying this because I work for them but no it really is a brilliant program and lovely university really and we're a really good team all you know we're happy to help brilliant I'll make sure we get the links for following Plymouth Uni in the show notes as well and tag you when this episode is coming out I've adored today I could talk to you more and more especially about Cornwall that sounds incredible thank you so much for your time today
oh you're most welcome. Really enjoyed it too. Yeah, thank you. Brilliant, thank you. Oh, thank you for listening. What an absolute pleasure speaking to Elise was and how good does Cornwall and the sea sound. We recorded this on a super hot day in August. We were both melting, which is why we decided,
I decided to go off camera today and just do audio by the time we started filming I'd not long got back from a run and got out the shower and I was like it's just so hot I'm so hot let's just keep it and let's just keep it on audio hope that hasn't altered your enjoyment if you are watching on YouTube. So what I should say is just at the end, Elise said, oh no, I forgot to mention something. So I said I'd do it in this section. So once you are a qualified CAP, you don't have to work for the NHS if you don't want to. You can also work in academia. So you can also work in universities, which is what she had done as well so I hope that's really useful because it obviously gives you more more scope for future
qualified work as well but how incredible does it sound I would love your thoughts around this episode if you wanted to come and join the group, which is totally free on Facebook, and do search for the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent, and in brackets it will say free group. That's how you know you're in the right place. Come and discuss what you thought to this episode. I'd love to know what you're thinking to it. Has it inspired you? Has it given you some more information?
Also, if you would like to join the waiting list for the next time the Aspiring Psychologist membership opens, do check out the details in the show notes. But I have loved today. I hope you have found it really useful as well. If you've got any ideas for future podcast episodes, do drop me a line. Otherwise, do please check out the dates for the compassionate Q&As to support the DeclinSci application season. They are totally free to attend and the details for how you can attend those will be in the show notes. But if you wanted to join the free Facebook group, it will definitely be in there. So come along and join so that we're nice and ready for when they start.
I will level with you. I can't quite remember when this episode will be going live because we've got some scheduled and in the can already but the first of the live Q&A sessions is actually on the 1st of September this year when they open which is Thursday. I'm not quite sure when this episode goes out so it might be that you can watch that on replay if it is indeed after the 1st of September and I'm desperately looking around for my diary but it's not in the room so I can't I can't end that mystery but yeah it's been a pleasure speaking with you today if you find the podcast useful please do like subscribe
comment tell your friends and rate and review on Apple Podcasts would be absolutely wonderfully gratefully received. Come and connect with me on socials. Most places I am Dr. Marianne Trent. I absolutely adore helping you to celebrate your successes. So do please come and connect. Yeah, and I will catch up with you very soon. Don't forget the next episode of the Inspiring Psychologist podcast is available for you to listen to from 6 a.m on mondays um but don't worry it will be here when you're ready um you don't need to set your alarm for 6 a.m um i hope you have a wonderful day whatever you're up to and thank you again for being part of my world take care If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified.
So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast
With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become clinical psychologists. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay
but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.